el punto clave del muy esperado
comunicado que este lunes presentó el
hospital abete aquí en berlín uno de los
hospitales principales de alemania y de
europa es que los hallazgos clínicos en
el caso del opositor ruso alexéi navalni
indican envenenamiento la sustancia
específica involucrada aún no ha sido
identificada según explicó el propio
hospital por lo cual son necesarias más
pruebas el hospital también explicó que
en avant y continúa en coma inducido en
cuidados intensivos y que si bien su
situación es grave su vida no está en
peligro lo cierto es que este tema se
está convirtiendo en un asunto político
de mucha importancia tanto en rusia pero
también aquí en alemania y de hecho la
canciller alemana angela merkel y el
ministro de exteriores hay comas
emitieron un comunicado conjunto algo de
por sí ya bastante inusual en el que
explicaron que dada la importancia
política que tiene naval ni en la
oposición en rusia las autoridades de
ese país están llamadas a esclarecer lo
ocurrido hasta el más mínimo detalle y
con transparencia y también a llevar a
los responsables ante la justicia